c'est donc il ya quatre ans c'était une
la dernière boulangerie et donc elle a
été transformée en salon de thé bar à
vins le nom de l'autre côté il y avait
un magasin de bonbons se transformer
aussi en boutique de vêtements moins
d'artisans plus de restaurants en
l'espace de quelques années le centre
ville de montceau les mines a changé de
visage
olivier travaille ici depuis 25 ans il
est l'un des tout derniers charcutier du
coeur de ville on va dire qu'il ya pas
mal de grandes surfaces sur mon sofa
donc voilà les gens vont en grande
surface et nous donc banon sur vivien
parce que tant que j'ai mis que j'aurais
aimé gratton j'aurai la clientèle qui
sera tout
si olivier parvient à tenir le coup
grâce à sa spécialité
difficile pour les indépendants de se
faire une place dans le centre ville
cette rue autrefois très passante a vu
de nombreuses boutiques fermer leurs
portes
remplacé par des grandes enseignes
c'était l'un des plus grands magasins de
vêtements pour mme demongeot boulot ni
bas il a tenu jusque dans les années
et puis cet opticien qui a remplacé tous
à la fin de l'activité minière l autre
responsable de cette transformation
depuis les années 90 montceau n'a fait
que perdre des habitants et aujourd'hui
c'est mon seul lien ont bien du mal à
reconnaître leur centre-ville
c'est beaucoup plus joli c'est sûr il ya
de la verdure mais il n'y a pas la joie
de vivre on ressent pas en ville la joie
de vivre qui avait g à 70 ans pour les
plus nostalgiques
c'est désormais sur les quais que les
habitants retrouvent ce contact avec les
artisans locaux
le marché hebdomadaire un rendez vous
toujours incontournable des gens comme
moi qui font encore le marché qui font
marcher le commerce local y en a encore
mais je suis comme tout le monde je vais
faire mes courses en grande surface et
là je reviens avec le caddie plein c'est
le monde moderne
voilà c'est le monde demandait
pour redynamiser les centres-villes
l'état engagé le plan national action
coeur de ville montceau-les-mines fait
partie des 2 122 communes sélectionnées